I have the privilege to present the
award to one of the five talented women
who were nominated as Best Actress in a
supporting role if there is apprehensive
as I was last year would be sadistic of
me to prolong the agony so the nominees
are
Annette Bening and the rippers Lorraine
Bracco and good fellow
Whoopi Goldberg in ghosts
diane ladd and wild at heart
[Applause]
[Music]
Mary McDonald in Dances with Wolves
[Applause]
[Music]
well in my heart ladies it's a five-way
tie but in this envelope is one name and
the Oscar goes to Whoopi Goldberg
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thanks
ever since I was a little kid I wanted
this you don't know my brother sitting
there you just think I would have to
listen anymore you can do it now my
mom's home everybody's watching I have
to thank the people at Paramount I have
to thank Jerry Zucker for taking the
time he took before he decided to use me
because it it meant he was sure that it
was for me I didn't think Patrick Swayze
was a stand-up guy and went to them said
I want to do it with her and I think to
me I want to thank everybody who makes
movies I come from New York as a little
kid I lived in the projects and you're
the people I watched your the people
wanted made me want to be an actor I'm
so proud to be here I'm proud to be an
actor and I'm gonna keep on acting and
thank you so much
[Applause]